here joining us on the rich eisen show
fresh off of winning his seventh
national championship as head coach in
the collegiate ranks
alabama head coach nick saban how are
you coach doing great how are you rich
better for talking to you um so uh
let's jump into it what what do your
days look like
in uh mid-february after winning it all
what what is a what is a typical nick
saban day
like right now for you well we spend the
first half of the day on football really
doing quality control type stuff
um you know based on our season evaluate
what we did on offense defense and
special teams and then we spend
most of the afternoon on recruiting
because we have to virtually recruit now
not being able to go on the road players
not being able to visit here
so um you know that's pretty much the
two things that we're focusing on
most you know here we'll start off
season program here in another week or
so
so we'll start getting back together
with our team
uh they're all lifting now but the
strength and conditioning coaches
basically
you know handle most of that so your pro
day is coming up
uh march 23rd just uh recently announced
uh
are you getting calls do you get calls
now from nfl talent evaluators
uh talking about your kids do you get
them right now nick
not not much um the closer we get to
that day
you know the more and more people start
to inquire about what's going on
so we're actually going to have two pro
days this year i just thought it would
you know since they have a limited
amount of people that can come to their
pro day
this year because of the covit situation
like they can only have three people in
each organization
i thought it would give them a little
bit more flexibility as to
um our players wanted to have two days
so if they couldn't send the receiver
coach
to see smitty on the 23rd they could
send them on the 30th so
we're actually having two days because
of that but the 23rd is the
is the main one and so what would you
say to an evaluator you referred to
smitty
um the heisman trophy winner devonte
smith
um what do you say to somebody who says
he's too small for the nfl what do you
say to somebody when they when they ask
about that sort of stuff or maybe you
hear these sorts of things
what do you say to that coach well i
think in our league
um you know you you're playing against
um sort of the it's not the nfl
i don't mean to infer that but you're
playing against a lot of big physical
players
in five or six games that we played uh
you're playing against big physical
players and both playoff games obviously
uh and the sec championship game and
you know lsu and georgia and there
there's a lot of
sec teams that look similar to nfl teams
i'm only saying that
because the size and speed factor that
everybody tries to equate
the small player to this guy's been very
durable here
and he makes plays against everybody and
he's hard to cover
and you can't i mean production to me
means a lot
um more than sometimes people give a
credit for
certainly more than measurables uh and
even though smitty will run fast and all
that to look at him and say he only
weighs 170 pounds there's a reason not
to pick them
i would say to them the ball weighs 13
ounces
how big do you have to be to carry it
i love that i've never heard that one
before where'd you pick that one up
you just came up with that yourself or
did you has been
it's been around for a while i just i
guess you know i've only been around the
nfl for 18 years i've never that's
i love that one that's fantastic so um
how do you decide whose house you
personally visit
how does that go about where you say
okay i'm i'm i
i want this kid no i'm gonna go
personally sit on the couch
in whoever's house uh i'm invited to
how do you decide that we haven't been
able to go sit on the couch for a little
while now because
of it but um you know we we do a an
evaluation system here very similar to
what we did when we were in the nfl we
got ready for the draft
um so we're going to rank the players at
every position
and obviously the guys that you feel are
the best players at every position are
the guys that you're going to have
the biggest priority to go want to see
you know first
um so that's basically in a nutshell
you know how we do it but i think
evaluation is the most
important thing and we we we have an
evaluation system just like we did for
the draft and
you know sometimes we like players
better than someone else and sometimes
they like players better than we do and
but we're always going to try to
prioritize the guys that we feel
fit our criteria the best for every
position
who's the guy uh coach in your and
wherever you've been
uh collegiately um who's the guy that
you recruited
you thought okay i i think this kid's
got a lot of upside
and then the upside blew the roof off
who's that one
that you went i guess from either couch
to podium with i
kind of blew you away look we've we've
had so many good players here i don't
know how many first-round draft picks
have we had
most of these guys are 30 some i think
in the 30s and probably another four or
five this year maybe
um you know julio jones was probably
as dynamic a player um and i always have
a special
place in my heart for you know those
guys that played back then because they
all came here when we weren't any good
you know we we were new here six and six
you know not not very good and um
you know a lot of those guys in that
first recruiting class marcel darius
mark baron
uh you know a lot of those guys i i kind
of have a special place for because they
all came here when we weren't any good
and
and uh really got the program going but
we've had so many great players here
it'd be hard to say
one guy actually you know
blew the roof off to use your term um
but the big thing i i these guys that
come here as high profile players in
high school
um and they get a lot of you know hype
now which which i'm happy for them to
get it and
a lot of positive self form but just
hate it when it
creates an expectation because they get
a lot of hype that they're going to come
in and make an immediate impact and
if it doesn't work out that way they're
frustrated you know because we want our
players here to focus on
you know not the outcome necessarily but
what do i have to do to get the outcome
that i want and
uh that's a mindset that i think is
important in their development
and you know sometimes when players get
frustrated they
they can't you know stay focused on that
few more minutes left here with nick
saban
uh head football coach alabama crimson
tide uh on the rich eisen show
would you be up for would you agree to
would you be opposed to
more college football playoff teams
more than just four uh
you know rich this is a historic
question i guess but
you know way back when we decided to
have
two teams pick the best two teams and
let them play in a championship game
uh and everybody wanted to expand the
four teams
it was my comment then that you know if
we expand the four teams and have a
playoff
uh everything is going to be about the
playoffs
um you know all the media interest
everything's going to be about to play
off the shows they do all year
looks like who gets in the ncaa
basketball tournament that's what it's
going to be and
all the other you know bowl games and
teams that had good seasons but didn't
quite get their
um you know the the interest in what
they do in the offseason is going to be
diminished and that's exactly what's
happened so
um i just wonder sometimes if having a
playoff in bowl games
uh and that was a unique thing about
college football a lot of a lot of
players got a lot of positive self
gratification for having good seasons
they got to go to a bowl game the their
families the program
everything you know sort of got some
positive self gratification for
what they were able to accomplish even
though they weren't
maybe national championship caliber or
playoff caliber and
you know now that's all been diminished
a little bit so you you just wonder to
yourself
can playoff and bowl games co-exist
uh or should we just have more teams in
the playoff i'm not saying i'm forward
or against it i'm just
i think that's the question that you
know people need to answer
so um so many different questions i
could have for you and i know i only
have a few minutes left
uh with you nick saban um how do you
decide which players you can get on
really hard and which not uh one of my
favorite stories i was told by paul
tagliabue once upon a time
is he was standing at a 50-yard line
with bill parcells in a practice for the
jets
and parcels was going all sorts of crazy
on players uh going through a goal line
drill 50 yards down the field
and tagliboo says we're the same age how
do you see that far down the field to
know who you're getting on coach
and parcells pulled a list out of his
pocket and he goes oh i just made up a
list of 10 guys i knew i was going to
get on today i'm on number seven stick
around i got three more to go
all the life parts so i love that story
how do you decide that you know which
kids you can you can coach hard or not
or or you just go the same speed and
they got to catch up to you
how do you decide that well first of all
i don't ever take a list on the field
with the intentions of getting on
somebody that particular day
okay um but i i think it's important to
know
the personality type of your player you
know we've had
you know i'm going to use
obsessive-compulsive type guys that are
you know really perfectionist really
want to get everything right really want
to do it right it's important for them
to do it right
and i think when you get on those kind
of guys um
it's not probably a good outcome i think
those guys
you just need to teach they're already
self-motivated they already want to do
well
so you need to teach them and you know
make sure they feel comfortable
and knowing what they're supposed to do
and how they're supposed to do it and
why it's important to do it that way
uh other guys uh that maybe are not as
motivated
to be the best version of themselves and
whatever it is
sometimes you need to get on those guys
a little bit and get their attention
and you know challenge them in terms of
is their behavior actually helping them
get to the goals that they want to
accomplish whether it's as a person as a
student or as a player in college but
uh and i think sometimes when you make
it about them and
because everybody's got to edit their
behavior to accomplish the goals that
they have and i think
when you allow them and let them know
maybe sometime in a harsh way
that what they're doing right now is not
really helping them going to help them
accomplish the goals that they have
it kind of sinks in pretty quickly with
them but
most of the time i try to teach you know
i i used to be one of those guys in the
old days that got on players a lot
and i just after a while i wondered
you know how much good is this really
doing when's the first time you met bill
belichick
nick saban what was that uh when i was
at the naval academy
um bill's dad steve was my
office mate 1981 and
bill used to come home in the summer and
see his parents and i think we were both
still in our 20s
you know in those days and we used to
get together and talk ball
and uh terry and i my wife and
um bill's parents were pretty good
friends and we'd get together and do
things and
um so that's when i first got to know
him and then
we just kind of built a relationship and
uh we'd meet and talk ball after that
even when i was at michigan state or
houston oilers or
um he was at the giants or whatever and
you know in the nfl you're not allowed
to
do that so i remember one time we snuck
to west point
i was at houston and you know jerry
glanville
said you can't talk to anybody else in
the nfl and bill was at the giants and
parcells had a rule you couldn't do that
so
we snuck up the west point stay in a
little hotel up there and
you know talk ball all weekend so um
i guess those two guys wouldn't get too
mad at us now that was a long time ago
yes i think the uh the statute of
limitations has uh
has expired on that so how often do you
guys talk ball now
how often do you chat uh we probably
don't talk
as much football but um
sometimes i'll have a question about
something i'll call him and ask him how
he'd
handle it or imagine it manage it uh you
know sometimes it's
it's program-oriented stuff sometimes
it's football-oriented stuff and
you know sometimes when he comes here
and um
visits with uh to see our players or
comes to pro day or whatever
you know we'll sit around and talk about
things some of them are philosophical
and some of them are
you know football related last one for
you coach saban
uh obviously urban meyer has been there
done that what advice would you
have for him now that he's trying the
nfl on for size
for the first time well you know urban's
always been a great coach in
in any place that he's ever been and
um i i got a good urban meyer story for
you okay
you know when i was a coach at houston
oilers
and i got the university of toledo head
coaching job
and the mac this would have been 19
maybe 89 or 90 or something
and um i'm still coaching for the
earliers i told him i'd finish the
season so i'm working every day
till midnight or whatever and miss
terry's home taking all the calls
so she has urban meyer calls the house
and he was at illinois state or
somewhere i i can't even remember but
um she talked to him and i came home
that night
and she said you know i talked to this
really interesting guy urban meyer
called and he's at this and he
she said you should make sure you talk
to him before you hire staff
and um probably one of the biggest
mistakes i ever made because i never
followed up i never took her advice on
that
and you know he's had such a great
successful career but
i think he'll do great in the nfl i
think the key to it is is you got to
have a great staff and you got to get
people in the organization on the same
page in the nfl so everybody's working
together and
if you can do that i know he's a good
coach and a good motivator and players
respect him
he'll help the players get better and
they'll have success
is there any thought in your mind about
maybe trying it
one more time in the nfl nixon no no
i i i know i just
i just feel like um you know at this
stage
stage in my career we we've invested a
lot in this program and
don't don't feel like going anyplace
else and starting over
would be something i'd want to do
because i feel like it's a new challenge
every year here
and i feel like i took a new job this
year you know we have five coaches leave
we have players going out for the draft
so
it's almost like starting all over and
rebuilding a program every year
and i just kind of look at it that way
and so i don't
i don't really think of well i need to
go someplace else to have a challenge
i got a challenge here all the time
coach really appreciate the time
um i could talk to you all day um i got
bruce arians on an hour number three and
he got some
bear bryant roots as you know he's uh he
just came off the podium
um and i i just i'm i have an
embarrassment of riches i get to talk to
champion uh head football coaches here
on the show i i cherish it so thanks for
the time appreciate it tell bruce i said
hello and uh congratulations all right i
will do that thanks for the call thanks
for watching
thanks nick saban alabama head football
coach hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that
watch more right here